اقر مجلس الوزراء السعودي نظام المعاملات
المدنيه بعد استكمال الاجراءات النظاميه
لدراسته في مجلس الشورى يعد النظام نظام
المعاملات المدنيه ثالثه مشروعات منظومه
التشريعات المتخصصه ويشتمل على احكام ايضا
تحدد جميع ما يتعلق بالعقود ياتي نظام
ايضا بهدف رفع كفاءه الانظمه وحمايه
الحقوق وتعزيز الشفافيه كما سيكون مرجعا
لتنظيم العلاقه ايضا بين الافراد في
تعاملاتهم وسيحد من حالات المنازعات بين
الافراد فضلا عن تقليل امد الفصل في
الخصومات
[موسيقى]
نعيد التذكير بما قاله الامير محمد بن
سلمان في لقاءه الشهير عام 2021 والذي اكد
فيه ان كل القوانين التي تسن في السعوديه
تتماشى مع القران والسنه وتعزز مصالح
الوطن والمواطن وتسن ايضا بناء على
القوانين المتعارفه عليها دوليا
العالم كله يعمل على انظمه واضحه وقوانين
واضحه
لتنظيم حياه البشر نحن دورنا ان كل
القوانين سلف المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تترجم واحد انها لا تخالف القران والسنه
القران
لا تخالف مصالحنا وتعزز مصالحنا تحافظ على
امن المواطن وتحافظ على مصالح المواطن
وتساعد في تنميه ازدهار
الوطن فتصن القوانين بناء على هذا الاجراء
حسب المتعارف عليه دوليا اذا تبغى سايح
يجيك مئه مليون سائح لخلق الف مليون وظيفه
وتقول انا عندي حاجه جديده اخترعتها
وغير القوانين
لن ياتيك اذا انت تبغى تضاعف مثل ما
ضاعفنا الاستمارات الاجنبيه من 5 مليار
ريال الى 17 مليار ريال وتقول له تعال
استثمر عندي لكن عندك اختراع جديد
لمحاميه يعرف
وشراءات اللي انت عاملها ولا يعرف كيف
تطبق ويحتاج يقول لك بلاها الاستثمار في
هذه الدوله لما تيجي تستقطب عقول
وقدرات بشريه للعمل في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتقول انا عندي اختراع جديد
لطريقه عمل قوانين القوانين لن ياتيك اي
اي احد فانت
تملا القوانين المتعارف عليها دوليا بناء
على دستورك القران وبناء على مصالحك وبناء
على مستهدفاتك وبناء على حفظ امن وصالح
المواطن والدفع بتنميه وازدهار الوضع انضم
الينا من الرياض نائب رئيس هيئه الكبرى في
مجلس الوزراء الدكتور عمرو رجب دكتور عمرو
اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره الرابعه ولن
يعني ما هو تعريف المختصر لهذا النظام
نظام المعاملات المدنيه وما هي اهميته
ايضا بالنسبه للمجتمع وكذلك للمستثمرين
مرحبا بدايه يعني اود ان اهنئ القياده
واهنئ مجتمع الاعمال اهم الوطن
والمنظومه القضائيه بصفه عامه المواطن
والمقيم على هذا البلد الطيب
بصدور الموافقه على على هذا النظام والذي
يعني بلا شك ويشكل نقله نوعيه في عمليه
الاصلاح
على جميع المسارات وبالذات فيما يتعلق
بالاصلاح القضائي وتحقيق رؤيه المملكه
النظام طبعا
يتناول هذا النظام
وضعت منهجيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بهذا بمشروع
هذا النظام بالنظام هذا النظام النظام ما
في شك يقوم على اسس
ثابته من بدايه اعداده الى حين الى حين
صدوره تتعلق في او شيء مراعاه احكام
الشريعه الاسلاميه
مواكبه المستجدات
والمتطوره والتطورات في الحياه المعاصره
والالتزام او الاخذ بافضل
المبادئ والنظريات القانونيه الحديثه
والممارسات القضائيه الدوليه واخيرا
مراعاه الالتزامات او التزامات المملكه في
الاتفاقيات الاتفاقيات التي ترتبط بها
دوليا
النظام المعاملات المدنيه يعني يغطي
جوانب كثيره تتعلق في جميع الجوانب
المتعلقه بالتعاملات المدنيه
في اقسامه
الثلاثه القسم الاول اللي اللي
يتناول بالتفصيل الاحكام المتعلقه
بالتزامات او بالحقوق الخاصه ومن ثم القسم
الثاني المتعلق بالعقود والقسمه الثالثه
المتعلق بالحقوق العينيه وبالتالي هو نظام
شامل يشمل جميع الاحكام ذات العلاقه او
المساس
بالملكيه بحمايه حمايه الملكيه استقرار
العقود وحجياتها منع الاضرار بالغير وما
هي اهم احكام تنظيم العلاقات القانونيه
التي يشتملها النظام بين الافراد
الحقيقه يتناول يتناول جميع جميع المسائل
التي يمكن ان
تتمخر عن اي التزامات
يقوم بها او يرى بالقيام بها الفرد او حتى
على على مستوى سواء الفرد او على مستوى
يعني المستوى المجتمع بشكل عام يعني جميع
الالتزامات المدنيه المتعلقه المتعلقه
سواء بالملكيه الخاصه ومتعلقه بالحقوق
والالتزامات
اللصيقه بالشخص الشخص الطبيعي
هذا النظام يعني ينظمها بشكل تفصيلي
ما هو الاثر المتوقع لهذا النظام
الحقيقه الاثر اثر اثر جدا عظيم
مثل ما ما جاء في في كلمه
سمو ولي العهد حفظه الله يعني هذا هذا
النظام
يعزز من مبادئ مبادئ كثيره مبادئ موجوده
ولكن هذا هذا النظام سيعزز هذه المبادئ
مثل مبدا الشفافيه مبدا حمايه حمايه
الحقوق
المبدا
القابليه التنبؤ بالاحكام وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاحكام الاحكام الصادره يعني من
القضاء واللي
يعني شوهد ان هناك بعض بعض الشواهد فيما
يتعلق باحيانا اختلاف او تباين الاحكام
فيما يتعلق بالوقائع المتشابهه
بل هو ذات النظام اللي تعمل يعني به دول
اخرى عربيه واجنبيه مثل فرنسا بريطانيا
وغيرها القوانين المدنيه اللي اللي تحكم
العلاقات الفرد والمجتمع بشكل عام
نعم نعم بخلاف يعني مسبى نظاما نظام يمكن
نظام الانظمه يعني كثير بالنسبه للتطبيقات
والمرجعيه والدراسات المقارنه اللي وقفت
عليها اللجان وفرق العمل اللي عملت على
على هذا النظام
رجعت الى يعني قوانين مدنيه هو هو يعد هو
القانون المدني هو القانون المدني لكن
التسميه قانون نظام المعاملات المدنيه وله
طبعا
تسميات مشابهه في في بعض الدول
استمديناها لن وصل يعني هذا النظام
حقيقه هو خلاصه التجربه تجربه العالميه
سواء تجربه التجارب
الاقليميه او التجارب الدوليه فيما يتعلق
ما يفترض ان يكون في القانون المدني هو
القانون هو الحقيقه هو القانون المدني هو
المظله واضح ولكن القوانين او ما يطلق
عليها القانون المدني في بعض القوانين
المقارنه
سلخت منه ما يتعلق بنظام الاسره ونظام
الاثبات وبالتالي وهذا اللي حصل يعني
المسمى نظام المعاملات المدنيه لان الان
هو هذا ثالث
الانظمه في منظومه التشريعات
المتخصصه اللي بدات في صدور نظام الاحوال
الشخصيه ومن ثم نظام الاثبات وهذا النظام
الثالث ويلحق باذن الله تعالى نظام
العقوبات